[Music]
the delilah khan video was going to be
clipped started their taper not when he
said [ __ ] wait [ __ ] sorry
sorry lacoons
stop saying that
it's not a bad word okay
you're [ __ ] weird why would she die
on the hill all the time merch god damn
it um
because i'm a coons oh okay um
sorry that was real you know the
algorithm when it does a transcript is
not going to know the inflection you're
putting on it
um
anyway this is the second half of the
kalila video um i know this is your
favorite part the things that she does
when she does poems uh this is called
no you have to i'm sorry i don't know
what sorry i don't want to do these ones
we have these
would further detail her manipulative
ways
sometimes when i drink coffee
i think i can rule the world
when i think i can rule the world i
think i can rule yours sometimes when i
drink coffee i picture you helpless like
a puppet on a puppeteer domineered by my
hands
sometimes when i drink coffee i'm bold
and rising sitting atop my hill of
prodigious hope waiting to slap the [ __ ]
out of you these
that's not really a poem that's just
like
this that's just a lunatic [ __ ] ranting
yeah
sociopathic tendencies are so blatantly
obvious that from the time of her very
first public appearance they would
already be widely acknowledged
in early 2014 kalila would appear on
episode 102 of the dvd asa podcast now
known as the pornhub podcast where she
would detail or open a relationship
prior to bobby
following this many negative posts would
appear on the dvd asa subreddit all with
high engagement numbers and extremely
positive upvote ratios with all this in
mind the recent breakup shouldn't be a
surprise to anybody it was even being
predicted long before it was made public
well i mean yeah
and this isn't even the first time bobby
and kalala have broken up either on
october 10th 2014 bobby would go on the
sam i'd rather dear his voice i'd rather
hear her poetry than you said sam
roberts
here murmured so that's him roberto
robert's friday show and explained that
him and kalyala had parted ways you're a
son of a [ __ ] because you said a minute
ago it's not been a good day for you
yeah
what's going on bobby
she left
she
my girlfriend
so wait okay
again shout out to to xlp
um
i didn't know this i did not know that
they had broken up before it's probably
something you know what happened here oh
you've seen that we've seen this happen
before too everybody's seen this happen
she probably that morning said we're
done we're broken up with but after the
show they reconciled and
caught him in that weird moment where
there's a lot of people that break up
that didn't really break up they
probably broken up several times yeah
yeah
it's always just for a weekend so they
both have an excuse to [ __ ] somebody
without feeling like [ __ ] well you know
what it is and i've learned this it's
the central trauma like will smith
taught me that it's like the central
trauma well that's why maybe we should
make make more time to face our traumas
and not like fixing our lawns yeah
we don't have time to fix houses
maybe maybe skip some sports ball sesh
yeah and maybe try to get into working
in your inner traumas and you have
plenty of time to work on that while
you're eating your bus lentils and
[ __ ] driving ah nothing like a nice
can of bus beans
nice and roof temp too nice in room temp
fighting a lot and warm they were in my
backpack
they heated by the sun oh that's what i
i know it shouldn't matter how it's
heated but for some reason that's gross
it's like it's um it's over now why is
it over well first of all what were you
fighting about
mainly destiny what does that mean the
streaming streamer the gayest thing i've
ever ever heard in my entire life
whether it's the streamer or like the
concept of destiny either way so if it's
just
were you fighting over like whether he's
a good debater
i don't know if you think about it how
are you destiny's a master debater how
ironic would that be if you and your
girlfriend broke up because you were
arguing about a guy who argues on
youtube for a little yeah
it's a video game
oh my god it was the third option it was
the bungee video game destiny
no he's got it's a joke he was probably
joking i'm not going to overreact
i thought you meant you were fighting
over like where you're going together
like what's your destiny together we
don't have destinies because we don't
live in like you know the lord of the
rings world right well that's silly and
i'm not going on adventures and
defending dragons and stuff no you're
fighting over the video game destiny
you're not fighting dragons you're
playing a video game kalila would post
about this situation eight days later
and her final entry on the website
titled bob two mics and a touch of love
i'm not going to read this entire thing
but after starting off the poem by
reminding us how insignificant our
problems are in the wake of the ebola
outbreak she would go on to come wait
wait
yeah ebola that was a
how about
that's some scary [ __ ] i don't know
kalila have you tried [ __ ] your
brother again i don't even know what to
tell you at this point honey i'm not
sure how that's gonna cure the ebola
it's i don't know it'll keep her quiet
for a little bit
it'll just get her brother ebola he's
dead remember he died of ebola no is it
ebola
he killed himself she said it
compare their relationship to that of
mike tyson my
choice michael spinks
yes really saying that she's felt like
both of them over the course of their
time together
she then goes on to complain about their
sex life saying
your anatomical shape why would you post
this publicly
like then what happens is she's into
humiliation then they cry no but then
but then these people cry when
fat idiots like us make fun of them but
it's like
it's different if this was you like
texting somebody and it leaked that'd be
like
that [ __ ] sucks like that [ __ ]
sucks that's not fair you should secret
recordings you should be allowed to have
private conversations with people but
when you're posting it on blogs like i
mean you you said you jerked off your
dog so much though that theo vaughn
almost just booked the trip to [ __ ]
to a different country
dude she's got a humiliation fetish as
far as doing it to people i think he's
got probably a humiliation fetish as far
as just being humiliated i think he
might be right it's not healthy but you
know it's none of my business yeah
instructure is not ergonomic no and i'm
immersed i agree with everything you say
it's none of your and i fear you but
it's like but then you can't com if you
make it public
you then can't complain because now
they're complaining and that's the
problem don't complain though you know
basically your overall design is
conducive it's like you know when porn
stars
try to go straight
like they want to oh my my pornstar
anymore i'm an actor podcast yeah or
whatever and then and then then you're
like people will only see me as that i'm
like yes
yes i'm sorry look i'm sorry once i've
seen your butthole
i don't know what you want else you want
me to think about talking to you
jennifer lawrence mm-hmm
for prison stop hope solo ill-sex only
never convict
conducive for prison style sex
never conventional doggy style
it's really sad if you think about what
still we revel in the oddities of one
another i like to spit in your mouth for
funsies
i delight in the reverberations of your
farts that sound like someone is making
popcorn for 12 theaters worth of people
okay man
bro
are we sure this isn't a work no i'm
hungry now i'm hungry and horny
popcorn
and popcorn
[Laughter]
i uh
it's so scary man
to think of somebody
who like you would you
that you would basically date like this
and they just want so much fame and
attention that like yeah i don't get it
nothing is off limits to talk about like
you know i'm not a guy that has a lot of
secrets and i'm not hiding much in my
life but there's stuff that like you
just you like to you know [ __ ] share
that you don't need to tell everybody
that and it's like ugh
this woman man i should collect snow
globes
it's true that's the secret that's the
secret that's he has an entire room
that's locked away the cats aren't even
allowed it's just the snow globes and
they're all like those [ __ ] uh like
disney everything's disney themes
if you collect look connecting snow
globes is bad but if you only collect
disney snow globes that's worse right an
antique one yeah it's just from 1963. oh
this is one that walt disney world walt
disney gave to goebbels actually when he
visited and toured disney this was the
one that was on joseph goebbels desk
when he was you know
let's just say at work are you sure
you're not connecting just nazi snow
globes it kind of seems like that's the
theme in this room this one belonged to
erwin rommel
he had picked two up when he came to
america one for his daughter
at the time and then one he wanted upon
his desk fun fact that's not snow those
are ashes
sorry
um snoozing globes and
just making it home in a bag
that would be the weirdest hot that
you've got to admit though
if somebody did collect like something
weird like that like snow globes or like
that or desk
like paraphernalia of nazi people
you would be kind of impressed you'd be
like that is kind of i only would have
been kind of impressed i'd want a home
tour i mean you [ __ ] kidding me
that stuff is cool
in argentina there's places in argentina
south america where there is actual
great grandchildren that have
this is my grandfather's and it was on
nazi memorabilia and it's weird they're
like these
blond-haired blue-eyed argentinians i
mean that [ __ ] it's always sunny
episode man
yeah it's one of my favorite episodes of
all time that was the wildest episode
ever was the grandfather oh god with the
painting
we are both demented both prone to
self-injury
some would argue that we are both
catastrophic human beings
i would argue that
they're probably right
did we just get vindication i think
they're definitely right oh wow she
would continue to make banal comparisons
between love and combat until eventually
begging bobby i love this guy
this guy rules i'm telling you by the
way we got him up to almost 350 now he
had he had three subs when we don't put
something up so put the link in the chat
i got you put the link in the chat this
guy did this i'm sure i followed him
already but yeah this guy this guy's
great very much for your strange love
i'd like to keep it
if you'll let me
this latest breakup doesn't appear to be
any different
bobby has talked about wanting to move
into a new more positive stage in his
life leaving all of this behind him as
he approaches old age eddie continues to
live with kalila housing her family and
even sleeping in the same bed as her
women are you guys still in that safe oh
yeah we played this this is the uh in
the same hill he plays yeah she's also
we sleep on the same bed what when
andrew schultz reacted there was so
like normal why
andrew schultz brought this up to him
saying that he was almost free and that
he needed to move into separate homes
immediately bobby acted as if this was
the plan yeah i mean he's almost free
yeah do you know what i mean but you
guys still live in the same place why
can't you guys be best friends imagine
you guys would be best friends and you
have your own places and she
you can do her thing
it sounds like he's talking to a child
it's it's the way he's pitching
the way it's supposed to be yeah yeah as
if it's some hot idea right like he's
the way he sounds like he's selling
bobby
yeah bro i got this brilliant idea for
you
but it's literally just describing what
any normal couple would do which is one
would move out and then you'd go the way
he's going like yo but check it out hear
me out b right all right so like instead
of what you doing right homie like all
right you break up and then you move
into separate places right and then
start dating other people you know what
i'm saying like that what do you think
what do you think no cap
busting bro he's making it like because
bobby's so [ __ ] you have to give him
a sales pitch to be a normal human being
the andrew schultzing is weird andrew
schultz is like only a year younger than
us and
he talks like
a wigger and it's weird to me you know
i mean you could do your thing there's
she is gonna there is a
a degree of wiggerism you're allowed to
retain
in your old age but then this feels like
too much wiggler this is too it's a
little like
it's a little too hey my fellow kids yes
exactly
she is gonna right yeah when they
inquired with kalila's niece who said
she had spoken to her about it she
didn't seem too convinced is that the
plan i think so you don't know
i just can't see khalil's niece because
it makes me miss frozen you know
rest in peace it really does i can't
believe he died all right that was a
blessing in disguise because it really
forced us to like tackle head-on because
i think we would have taken much longer
to deliberate
so there you have it our boy the gringo
poppy himself has single-handedly freed
bobby lee from the clutches of the
succubus
after revisiting their beef i don't even
think it's too fun
here's the thing cause everyone what's
happening here is and you've said this
many times but i remind everybody
everyone here is sitting around taking
sides
the one thing that everybody needs to
remember that's the most important thing
this is okay i know where you're going
with this all of these people are
terrible
all of these la
comic
circle jerk thing that you see here look
i get it i probably ain't gonna be
[ __ ] ever be invited in one of these
puck and that's fine i'm fine with that
but
i am not even talking about this whole
kalila thing and bobby thing they are
narcissistic drug abusing
sneaker collecting like for like peter
pan 40 year olds
who are on a cocktail of prescription
drugs yeah see a therapist four times a
week
and every week they're worse than they
were the week before yeah they're all
terrible that being said i am glad that
out of everybody in this universe that
blundering idiot brendan schaub just
torpedoed bombingly's relationship
i want to bring something of all people
if we're doing that if we're doing the
neverland thing then bobby bobby lee has
to be rufio because he's filipino so
that makes the most sense
this this would be like um
uh
who's like a batman uh not a batman
who's a superman uh
uh
who's one of his
scarier opponents superman yeah
doomsday all right so this would be like
bizarro superman
stumbling in and accidentally tackling
and strangling tuesday to death
i guess you're right and then you're
like i still have to defeat bizarro
superman but
yeah you took them out pretty good there
that's it's like a school shooter
stopping a rape
[Laughter]
that's one of the funniest things i've
ever heard in my entire [ __ ] life
that's this entire saga you're watching
here
he killed 40 kids but he killed the
rapist he was about to rape a kid he was
about to rape that kid
is dead but
um
that's what this is
i can show it to you here's the thing
this is what's interesting explain this
however you want
when i notified you guys of the
harassment and going back to tiger belly
that account stopped posting
took the tiger belly email off and
changed it it's never posted again she's
definitely not the mastermind behind the
subreddit that's his own stupidity but i
would not be surprised at all if she
spends countless hours sitting on burner
accounts talking crazy [ __ ] about
everybody take this entry from august
4th
2014.
nobody reaches you never shut up
too much
today's paper
you were a mild encounter
dull predictable assembled for safety
and all things snooze
you were unworthy of a memory unworthy
of a story told more than once to a
stranger who inquired about the meaning
of the word on we
i would say i'm sorry that the paleness
of your every move and the flatness
is there anything worse than a bishop
things are smart
they learn a couple tree words and then
yeah
sounds like a script for an elliott
rogers video yeah it is it is
[ __ ] robert frost i think that's
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
again i posted the link by the way this
is very well done
so yes xlp shout out to xlp